we've got another story here that I want
to try to push into Pixar the the
Beloved children's film producer which
for a very long time couldn't seem to
miss has been doing worse and worse over
the years and many people are
speculating it's because of wokeness
well now their new film Elemental has
absolutely bombed at the box office
doing worse than any of Pixar's films
have ever done and it just happens to
feature their first
non-binary character so are those two
things related is this just a product of
the new Marketplace and streaming
services it's certainly possible but I
just want to start by highlighting some
of the figures here firstly Elemental
opened to about 29.5 million dollars its
first weekend which is the worst opening
in Pixar's history to be clear Toy Story
made
29.1 million it's opening weekend back
in 1995 5 and it had a 30 million dollar
budget okay so accounting for inflation
Pixar's first film when they were a
totally unknown Studio which did not
have hit after hit after hit and a
well-proven brand blew this current film
absolutely out of the water Elemental
compared to Toy Story's 30 million
dollar budget had a 200 million dollar
budget and not to belabor the point made
the exact same amount it's openings
and face value numbers I'm not talking
about real income I'm not talking about
real Revenue I am not talking about
inflation-adjusted numbers I am talking
about the actual raw figures so they
need to have 10 opening weekends just to
break even on the on the production
budget forget the marketing yep yep
that's just the production budget and so
and money's not free anymore by the way
no it is
I watch a lot of these videos about guys
talking about what uh representation and
equity and diversity have done to Disney
and to Marvel and what what very few of
the people are talking about is the cost
of capital it's not enough to break even
when you break even you're saying that
the three years that we spent nursing
this 500 million dollars on this project
yep we didn't lose it well actually you
did lose it because the interest on 500
million dollars in the last three years
is real money I mean for you for guys
like you and me it's real money for you
not so much but yeah no not not Ian
he'll he'll be fine but no even for
these massive companies I mean this is
again this is uh another example and
probably the worst example at least for
Pixar in a trend that we've seen over
the past several years and part of it is
these streaming services and the fact
that people know that if a film doesn't
really catch their interest all that
much they don't need to take the kids to
see it opening weekend they can see it
later on but also there is an element I
think of wokeness political correctness
and trying to push leftism in children's
media that has affected the revenue that
a lot of these companies are seeing so
an example we saw about two years ago
one or two years ago I believe was the
Buzz Lightyear spin-off film that was
released and it did abysmally and people
were saying that this wasn't a product
of the fact that there was a lesbian
kiss in the background of the film and
parents were totally fine with that and
they chose not to see it for other
reasons and it's true that some people
might have chosen not to see the film
for for other reasons but the reality is
two of the top 10 highest earning
children's films of all time are Toy
Story films right and then they release
a spin-off film and I'm not going to go
as far as to say it bombed but it
performed very poorly given that
franchise's track record and people may
want to argue if they're on the left
that the fact that there is a lesbian
kiss in a Toy Story movie didn't affect
its marketability or whether parents
would choose to take their children to
see it but I think that's flat on its
face absurd and I think the idea that
parents were in no way affected by a
non-binary character being in this
children's film is equally absurd even
if streaming did play a role
what
I started out wanted to ask a different
question but I think I think I've
answered that one and I have a new
question
my original question had been at the
beginning we talked about Target
and you know Middle America not wanting
to take their kids into a Target store
because of the freaky things that
they're selling and now we're talking
about Middle America not wanting to take
their kids to a movie theater because of
the freaky things they're selling yep
and in the middle we talked about how
Americans don't give a
they'll just vote Democratic no matter
what and Democratic has completely
embraced the Democratic party has
embraced this entire there's a
disconnection here
the answer seems to me to be
that
General feel-good political allegiances
and voting
are hard to dislodge
and even though we can always find and
do always find
social media sharing
of footage from footage the old man said
footage yeah we developed it in the dark
film okay the video
of the you know family-friendly drag
show
and you're wondering what the hell
family what parents are taking their
kids but by and large at the end of the
day most normal Americans
will even vote democratic
will even believe the media and the
implausible
stories that they come up with about
origins of the of you know of covet
they when it comes to
pressing pushing this sexual
sexualization even forget whether or not
it has to do with homosexuality or
transsexuality or any of that stuff
sexualization of children people still
have I think in normal people and that's
still the majority
an inherent
revulsion why does my kid have to be
involved with this at all agreed agreed
I think that's the right way of putting
it it's a revulsion a person doesn't
have to go through like an intellectual
rationalization for why they're not
taking their kid to see that they just
go that's the disgusting I don't want to
show that to my kid they feel it in
their gut and they say this isn't for
our family and they do something else
they don't need to explain it to
themselves I think that's the hard thing
about modern culture for a lot of
parents they're being pressed to say but
why wouldn't you do this why won't you
do that and they don't have a religious
Doctrine to fall back on because they
don't go to church anymore and they
don't observe you know the tennis of
their religion and yet their souls are
screaming within them amen that there is
right and wrong in this world that there
is certainly call it natural law call it
God's but there is morality that there
are things that matter there are values
that are not malleable and people are
embarrassed to be associated with a
religious
um rationale for having those feelings
because what could be less fashionable
well and I think this is why it's so
important to the alphabet people to go
after children because it is true as you
said this is this is written on man's
heart he understands this there are
certain things that are wrong and
when a child sees something grotesque
for the first time they're going to
respond as they are naturally inclined
to I'm not saying everything that we
feel internally is indicative of a moral
reality sometimes we're wrong but in
general especially when it comes to
sexually perverse behavior when
someone's exposed to it they recoil they
find it to be disgusting so the reason
they want to show it to Children is
because what they're effectively doing
is a kind of perverse exposure therapy
which we usually call grooming but of
course because the left wants this
particular form of grooming to continue
they're not allowing people to call it
that but that's exactly what it is we
need to try to expose children to this
and then Gaslight them out of following
that initial internal sense of revulsion
towards the perversity in front of them
and it doesn't have to even be
perversity as I said the entire most
normal young children are uncomfortable
with
outward displays of what we might call
romantic affection they don't really
want to see Mommy and Daddy kissing a
kiss is okay they don't they don't want
to see you making out with your spouse
they do not want any part of that as
they shouldn't like an adult wouldn't
but but if you wanted to create a world
where like adults were just making out
in front of each other and in front of
kids and being weird then you'd go to
San Francisco you'd go to San Francisco
no but that's what these groomers do
they they try to expose children to it
as early as possible to them it becomes
normal to them exactly exactly I think
it's also important to mention that a
lot of the people that are performing in
Dragon Etc and in these in these
environments I mean I was a DJ for years
and I've been around a lot of the gay
community say what you will about it but
they don't feel comfortable doing this
they don't want children to be around
like that and a lot of them are in the
situation where they're essentially
being forced by people that are yeah I
represent a couple of organizations um
one is one is a gays against groomers
yes okay great people and these are you
know these are these are real homos
these are in other words these are
people who they're not they're they're
they are they're certain they are
they're actually they're they're you
know it is it is a big part of their
identity another I mean you know there's
like an entire different conversation of
does tolerance of homosexuality require
me to have to hear about your homosexual
interest all the time separate apart
from that what my clients are saying is
they're killing our community yes
they're killing the reputation and the
image we had and by the way
there's a parallel to what's happened
with with race relations in this country
because most of us
until Barack Obama was not only until
Barack Obama was elected
but especially after Barack Obama was
elected but we did it
we on race relations yeah we've done we
have turned that corner we can elect and
that and by the way many many many
people voted for him to demonstrate to
themselves exactly that I'm not racist
they're not right I voted for a black
president and what happened is the door
was opened to a radicalization not
necessarily because of Obama himself I
don't think so but because of people
around him I actually don't have that
sort of really intense uh hatred of
Obama that a lot of people do uh and
then you should probably talk to someone
I mean you should get get that checked
out not hatred strong dislike I strongly
dislike him
yeah but we're going here the strong
dislike but continue continue no I bet
the point is the point is the the people
thought that we had we sort of had the
sexual Revolution and a lot of morality
moral choices were Unbound and
traditional
and we were not necessarily all of us
that comfortable especially those of us
and who are traditional religionists
fine fine you you know you go and ruin
your own Society
we're gonna just hunker down
it's inescapable now exactly nowhere
they won't let and by the way and that's
always how it Trends by the way they're
never okay doing their perverse thing
and then leaving other people alone to
live their traditional lifestyle there's
never a limiting principle nope and
there can't be because
when their entire argument for
recognition and acceptance and tolerance
is premised on marginalization per se is
an is an evil that means that there is
no margin on in which you can leave the
most
perverse behavior and there we are yep
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time